This video is part of yet another big history
YouTube collaboration, this time talking about
various events in French history, but more
on that later.
As always before talking about the main point
of the video, the Paris commune, we have to
understand the events that lead up its creation.
Btw I am going to mispronounce every single
French word in this video I apologize ahead
of time.
So during the time leading up to 1871 France
was an empire, the Second French Empire to
be exact, led by Napoleon the third.
The same guy who installed Maximilian 1st
on the Mexican throne but I digress.
So ever since Napoleon the third uncle's defeat
at Waterloo, France was very politically unstable.
Well it was also politically unstable before
then but we don’t have time to get into
that.
After Waterloo, the Bourbon dynasty was reestablished
in 1815, and outside of the republican leaning
Parisians this was initially accepted by the
majority of French people who finally wanted
some stability after all of the bloodshed
that happened.
Plus the new bourbon ruler Louis the 18th,
for obvious reasons, made sure to be a more
liberal monarch than his brother was but when
he died and his son Charles the 10th came
into power, a lot of the French people became
again very disgruntled with the monarchy as
Charles was a much more conservative monarch
then his father was.
This angered many people especially in Paris
whose inhabitants were far more republic leaning
than the rest of the country.
Therefore in 1830 the July revolution started
in Paris, the Parisians where initially supported
in this by the rest of the country and within
“the three glorious days” the Bourbon
monarchy was overthrown, however, this is
where the revolutionary movement divided with
most of the Parisians and some other big French
cities wanting a republic and the rest of
France just wanting a less conservative monarch,
therefore once the dust had settled the bourbon
monarchy was replaced by a more liberal monarchy
under the new Orleanist dynasty.
This establishment of a new, even though liberal
monarchy, was seen as betrayal by the Parisian
as they wanted a republic not a monarchy.
Therefore in 1832 they staged another Parisian
rebellion but this time it was unsuccessful
and so the monarchy remained.
But the status quo wouldn’t hold long as
in February 1848 during the year of revolutions,
Parisians rose up again and successfully overthrew
the Orleanist monarchy, forming the Second
French Republic.
This republic yet again gained a more conservative
character over time as most of ruler France
were still monarchists.
Seeing the conservative shift of the republic
Parisians rebelled yet again that same year
known as the June Days uprising.
This was unsuccessful and the conservative,
at least to the Parisians, Napoleon the third
was elected as the president of the second
French Republic who then four years later
proclaimed the establishment of the second
French Empire.
During this entire time Parisians became more
and more disgruntled, as they have rebelled
and rebelled only for their dreams of a republic
to be always crushed by the more conservative
leaning ruler France that wanted a monarchy.
Due to this feeling of suppression, during
the second French empire Paris became a hotbed,
even more than it was before, for leading
leftist ideas.
By 1870 Paris was full of Marxists, Jacobins,
Anarchists, but also more milder socialists
and all kinds of other leftists who had a
hard time agreeing on stuff other than that
the monarchy must go.
This is not to say that there were no monarchy
supporters in Paris or that every person who
supported one of these movements believed
in all of its ideas but many of the working
class people of Paris whose numbers have been
growing steadily due to industrialization,
felt alienated by the monarchy and wanted
a republic, but seeing the years of failure
to establish a republic meant that many of
these people ended up being drawn to more
radical ideas as the only way to achieve this
goal.
This movement of Parisian working class people
towards more radical ideas was further exacerbated
by Napoleon's actions towards Paris, not only
due to fears of yet another Parisian revolution
was Paris denied a city council, a benefit
that many other cities in France had, but
Napoleon also started extensive Parisian building
projects which created large beautiful boulevards
for the rich while destroying a lot of working
class housing in the process.
This meant that Paris was well ready for another
insurrection if given the chance and such
a chance came during the 1870 to 71 Franco
Prussian war.
The mood in Paris at the start of the war
was surprisingly one of ultra patriotism,
because the thing that the Parisians hated
even more than the French monarchy were the
Prussians.
However, France was completely stomped by
the Prussians with Napoleon and his 80k strong
army being defeated and captured at Sedan.
When the news of Napoleon's capture came to
Paris the city wasted no time and another
Parisian revolution established the French
third republic, although at the moment due
to being in an active war the new provisional
government was just called the Government
of National defence.
The Prussians were at first not sure whether
the new Parisian Government of National defence
was legitimate or whether it would continue
with the war but seeing that the government
quickly started to mobilize new troops across
France and made it clear to the Prussians
that it was definitely not surrendering the
war resumed with Prussia quickly advancing
and besieging Paris in September 1870.
The French army stationed in Paris tried breaking
the siege the first few months but was unsuccessful
suffering high losses, and therefore it didn’t
try such a move again.
During this time the new minister of war Léon
Gambetta flew over the Prussian siege of Paris
in a balloon so he could help mobilize a new
French army outside of Paris with which he
would later come and relieve the city.
Meanwhile in Paris the situation started to
slowly deteriorate.
Many high class people of the city, most of
whom owned much of the shops and industry
within Paris, left before the Prussians siege
started.
This meant that the middle and lower class
people, many of whom couldn’t even afford
to leave the city, were now stuck in a siege
with no work as much of the industry outside
of military manufacturing had been closed.
Due to this many of the working class people
started to enlist in mass into the national
guard since that remained the only reliable
paying job within the city.
The national guard was an amature military
force organized by the Government used to
support the main military in times of need
like the current siege of Paris.
Due to all these new enlistments the national
guard in Paris swelled up to around 300 to
350 thousand men, this was at least twice
as much as the number of professional French
soldiers in Paris at the time.
The national guard along with many Parisians
was very fervent despite the armies inability
to break the siege, they thought that with
their numbers and zeal they could easily break
the siege and push the Prussians out of France.
The army however, knowing better wouldn’t
let them attack and so the siege continued
while the food shortage in the city became
more and more problematic.
The food situation in Paris was so diare in
fact that there are reports of Parisians eating
horses or even rats to stay alive and one
Parisian even wrote that a desperate woman
came up to him offering sexual favors for
nothing more than a piece of bread.
All this, combined with the Parisian and national
guard vehement belief that they could defeat
the Prussians if only the army and the government
would let them, resulted in growing resentment
in Paris against the government.
Not only are they not allowing the national
guard to attack the Prussians, they’re not
attacking them themselves, not to mention
that the new mobilized french army that Léon
Gambetta so famously flew on a balloon to
go organize didn’t come to relieve the city
as promised.
This was because the Prussians defeated all
the new mobilized armies of the third republic
but due to blocked communication lines Parisians
didn’t know this at first and once they
did find out they blamed the new government
for the losses anyways, some Parisians going
as far as to say that the new government wanted
to lose to the Prussians.
After many Parisian demonstrations and even
an unsuccessful attempt at a coup, the army
along with the government finally allowed
the national guard to salvie out in January
to try to take some key points outside of
the city.
The National guard in a fervent zeal with
no real plan attacked the Prussian lines head
on only to be utterly defeated.
One of these fervent revolutionaries wrote
“At first the National Guard swept the Prussians
before them, but the mud defeated the brave
son of the people.
They sank into the wet earth up to their ankles,
and unable to get their artillery up on the
hills, they had to retreat.
Hundreds stayed behind, lying quietly in death;
these men of the National Guard, men of the
people, artists, young persons, died with
no regrets for their lost lives.
The earth drank the blood of this first Parisian
carnage; soon it will drink more.”
Despite this unsuccessful break through, the
fact that all the French armies were defeated
and that most of Eastern France was under
Prussian occupation, the Parisians remained
adamant that they could still win the war,
somehow, therefore when the government signed
an armistice with the Prussians 28th of January,
Parisians felt back stabbed by the new republic,
how could they surrender, how could they negotiate
Peace when the jule of France the capital
city still has not fallen to the enemy.
Despite these Parisian feelings the war was
over and the Government of National defence
held an election across France in February
1871 to replace it; this newly elected council
was meant to negotiate the peace terms with
Prussia and later determine how France would
continue after the war.
The council had 650 seats with Paris having
42 of those.
All 42 elected members from Paris were leftists
that supported the continuation of the war,
however another 400 seats mostly coming from
rural France were former monarchists wanting
peace, the council selected a guy named Thiers
as the new head.
Parisians viewed the election results in horror,
too many times have they created a republic
only for the rest of rural France to form
yet another monarchy, and it was happening
again.
And just as you thought that the Parisians
couldn’t hate the new government more than
they already did a series of events made it
possible.
Not only did the new government settle on
a peace deal with Prussia which acknowledged
the French defeat an outcome which as stated
was hated by the Parisians but they also allowed
the Prussian army to hold a parade in Paris.
A city that as far as the Parisians were concerned
wasn’t conquered by the Prussians and therefore
they had no right to hold a parade in it.
However, the parade happened anyways and the
Parisians were so horrified by this that there
are accounts that after the parade ended some
Parisians went outside to wash the very street
the Prussians walked on as to cleanse it from
the German stench.
With that said the Prussians didn’t leave.
They just camped outside of Paris and waited
until the war reparations defined in the peace
deal were paid by the French.
So as I talk about the following events keep
in mind the Prussians were just there watching
it all happen.
Anyways since the war was over now Thiers
started to implement some new laws to try
to start up the economy of the capital city,
however, these laws seemed more targeted at
trying to agitate the Parisians than anything
else.
For example Thiers lifted the paus on rent,
significantly lowered the pay of the National
Guard and lifted the moratorium on debts and
pawn shops.
This was significant because Parisians went
into debt or pawned a lot of their possessions
during the siege to try to get money to buy
food, thinking that since the moratorium was
in place on debts and pawnshops they could
just pay the debts and buy their stuff back
once work resumed in the city.
But work didn’t resume in the city in fact
even more shop owners and businessmen who
weren’t able to leave the city before the
siege left now since Paris during this entire
time was very unstable with protests against
the new government happening on a daily basis
and unpredictable armed national guards were
roaming the streets.
Even military manufacturing, the last working
industry in the city, stopped since the war
was over.
All of this meant that Thier’s actions that
were meant to get the money flowing again
through the economy just angered the Parisians
even more since they had no money and there
was no work to get more money.
Therefore by March 150 thousand bankruptcies
were declared in the city.
With all this happening the last straw was
when Thiers ordered the army to disarm the
national guard starting with capturing it’s
cannons, and ou boy they couldn’t have chosen
a worse target.
You see these cannons were very symbolic to
the Parisians, not only where they built in
Paris for the war, but they were paid off
by donations from the Parisians so they could
defeat the Prussian siege.
Those cannons symbolized everything the Parisians
had fought for in the past few months and
the government which they hated was now trying
to take the cannons away from them.
Naturally a fight broke out between the two
sides and due to the incompetence of the military
officers in charge, the Parisians managed
to win, capturing two military officers and
executing them.
Hearing this news and seeing the insurrection
now happening all across Paris Theirs with
the government decided to relocate to Versailles
on the 18th of March.
Paris now being abandoned by it’s only governing
body, since remember Paris had no city council
it was directly controlled by the main French
government, decided to create and appoint
their own city council since they needed someone
to govern them.
They named this new city council the Paris
Commune, this name contrary to popular belief
has nothing to do with communism, commune
just means city or county council in French,
in fact there are currently over 36 thousand
communes in France.
The makeup of this city council which met
for the first time on the 28th of March was
interesting to say the least.
It was a hodgepodge of all kinds of leftist
groups, from simple republicans to marxists,
jacobins, anarchists, blanquists, etc.
Plus even though the council had 92 members
only 60 of them ever bothered to show up to
the meetings, with the rest either recognizing
the Versaille government or not wanting to
be elected in the first place.
One Parisian summarized the members of the
council by saying “the names of the men
in the new government posted, [are] names
so unknown that it seems like a joke”.
This statement was quite apt, since many of
the council members were simple workers and
artisense who before this never held any administrative
position in their life.
But despite this many Parisians still felt
quite emboldened by one saying “Paris and
the whole country must know the nature, the
reason the aim of the Revolution which is
being carried out.
And the responsibility for the mourning, the
suffering and the tragedies of which we are
victims must fall on those who, after having
betrayed France and sold Paris to the foreigner,
are pursuing with blind and cruel obstinancy
the ruin of the capital in order to bury in
the disaster of the Republic and liberty the
dual witness of their treason and their crime.”
So as Parisians established their own city
council, they never actually declared independence
from France, or some kind of a war on France
or even their own independent governance,
in reality they just established their city
council which they still saw as part of the
same greater administration and were trying
to decide what to do next.
With, yes, some people like the person I just
quoted proposing a communist revolution or
attack on the government in Versaille but
others, which were the majority, were hoping
to negotiate with the Versaille government
on terms such as Paris getting its own city
council, more rights to the workers, the abolishment
of Thiers’s economic laws, etc.
But Theirs was having none of it, he declined
to negotiate with the commune and quickly
labeled the insurgency in Paris as a revolution
that needs to be put down, then he started
massing troops for an attack on the city.
This meant that the Paris commune without
actually declaring independence became independent
for a period of less than three months.
This is when most of the laws cited by people
talking about the commune were passed by the
council.
A vast majority of these never got implemented
due to a lack of time, funds and sometimes
just apathetic nature of the populace towards
some of these laws.
However some notable laws passed outside of
abolishing all Thiers’s economic laws where,
the separation of church and state, abolishment
of the death penalty, the continuation of
production in military factories, the restarting
of production in closed and abandoned factories/workshops,
abolishement of conscription, etc.
All of these points however have their caveats.
Yes conscription was abolished but now every
healthy working adult was considered as being
automatically part of the National Guard which
was the main military body of the commune.
Yes the commune abolished the deaf penalty
but some radical members of the national guard
did execute several priests and or people
deemed to be spies of the Vareaile government.
Yes the workers were given the right to resume
production in abandoned factories and workshops
basically managing it all themselves but the
commune never nationalized anything they still
recognized all the original owners rights
to the factories and businesses.
The commune even negotiated with the Bank
of France to give them a loan to fund all
of this.
By the way the Bank of France was located
in Paris, pretty defenceless and still full
of gold since the Versaille government didn’t
have time to move it.
But despite this the communards decided it
would be better working with the Bank rather
than nationalising it.
The reason why all these actions of the commune
weren’t actually so communist was because
the city council as mentioned before was very
divided, with many people following more milder
leftist ideas than others, therefore often
times compromises had to be made, hence the
laws passed by the commune where leftist but
not very marxist, or anarchist.
The commune existed in this weird lymbo state
until sunday 21st of May 1871 when Thiers
finally having a big enough army attacked
Paris.
What followed next was brutal street to street
fighting between the French forces and the
National Guard, buildings were lit on fire,
barricades erected, and hundreds of Communards
killed/executed when captured.
There was no winning for the commune and many
of them knew this, surrendering the first
chance they got but many were also very radicalized
at this point, refusing to surrender and fighting
to the last breath.
It took the french forces an entire week to
finally take control of the entire city, a
week which is remembered today as the Bloody
Week.
And so 28th of May the Paris commune ended,
existing for only 71 days.
There were around one thousand French army
deaths and depending on who you ask around
5 to 25 thousand communard deaths.
Thiers had no mercy for the captured communards,
with some of them being executed and others
exiled or deported to the furthest French
colonies.
Thiers’s very provocative actions towards
Paris after the Franco-Prussian war has led
some historians to believe he agitated the
population on purpose trying to instigate
a revolution that he could then put down and
that way solidify control, others say he was
just very incompatent, and most likely it
was a mixture of both.
But one thing Thiers made sure of by the way
he ended the commune was that he created a
giant symbol for the radical leftist in Europe.
The way Thiers branded the commune an enemy
from the get go, the fact that he completely
refused negotiating with them and the way
he ended its existence in a Bloody Week meant
that he created thousands of martyrs for the
European radical leftists.
Many leftist thinkers like Marx quickly jumped
on this opportunity and wrote about the commune
as an idealised communist state that was brutally
destroyed by the upper classes, and if only
it would have done certain things differently
like nationalizing the bank it would have
succeeded in taking down the Versaille government,
but none of this was really true.
The Paris commune was leftist yes but it definitely
was not some glorious communist state or an
active revolution of the whole proletariat,
nor outside of a few radicals did it want
to take down the Versaille Government, it
was far from any idealized communist revolution
as portrayed by Marx.
But this did not matter, many of the leftist
movements of the following decades needed
a symbol and the Paris commune became that
symbol.
When the bolsheviks took power in Russia they
saw the commune as their predecessor and started
buying up every possible commune memorabilia
they could get their hands on.
An original Communard red flag is buried with
Lenin to this day and another communard red
banner was sent to space by the USSR in 1964.
Due to all this communist idealisation of
the Paris Commune the commune is today remembered
as one of the first comunist states in history
which isn’t really true, it was a new thing
and was on the left side of the political
spectrum but it definitely was not communist.
This video is part of Project France where
9 other History YouTubers talk about various
other parts of French history with many of
them also doing some small collabs with each
other's videos.
So it's a sort of colab within a colab.
If you want to watch all these videos you
can find the link to the playlist in the top
right corner or at the top of the description
or pinned the comment honestly the links to
the playlist are everywhere so there shouldn’t
be any excuse to not go watch the playlist.
I hope you enjoyed the video, I know I didn’t
have time to talk about the women's role in
the commune, or Jaroslaw Dobrowsky involvement
in it, or the whole division of the city council
into different administrative entities in
the latter half of the commune’s existence,
or the ridiculous way the National Guard was
actually structured, (etc.) but as always
there's only so many things I can talk about
in one video.
This video was made possible thanks to my
amazing Patreons, thank you very much.
My name is M. Laser and as always stick around
for history.